so thank you for the introduction
Michael and thank you all for the
opportunity to speak to you today I'm
really excited to share the findings
from my current work so this is a
project that me and my team are still
actively working on but I'd like to
share with you the findings so far so
that it is a HTI community we can start
thinking about how to incorporate people
in the process of building AI and not
just users of the AI but also those who
are affected by those AI or algorithmic
decisions so as Michael mentioned I got
interested in this question when I first
looked at how Oberer drivers work with
their app when it was first introduced
to Pittsburgh in 2014 so in uber and
lyft an algorithm was making seemingly
very simple decisions making a matching
drivers to clients but it was affecting
the kinds of jobs they were drivers get
and the income that they make and what
was striking to see was the drivers were
technically users of the app but they
were not giving much control in the way
they choose a work and that route that
they take to the work and those were
completely affected by these algorithms
and since then the use of algorithm that
managed or govern our everyday life
seems to have grown exponentially
they don't just decide our what we see
online they they are increasingly making
managerial and governess decisions in
workplaces schools hospitals and cities
and even influencing medical judicial
and policy decisions so stakes are
pretty high but why are our griddles are
used to automate so many decisions
because they make operations more
efficient and they're backed by the
promises that data-driven insights will
improve the decisions and work but
however there are in
in many real-world cases when the
systems have also made unfair and biased
decisions so in response to their
growing use there has been increasingly
more scholarly attention to this topic
in public domains is called algorithmic
governance and in private sectors
algorithmic management and in both cases
algorithms are automating or augmenting
decision human decision maker used to
make conceptual studies of these
algorithm have criticized trends and
laid out the potential risk of such
automations an emerging empirical work
including some of my old work seeks to
understand the how of automations
may impact decision making practices
that governing institutions and how
citizens and workers perceive those
decisions so for example my work
suggests that people perceived algorithm
making hiring or performance evaluation
decisions less fair compared to when
humans are making those decisions and
even with simple task of assigning goods
people deem the algorithm allocation
less fair than humans because it ignored
important social contexts and nuances so
the question that I asked in this
project complements this line of work
understanding the impact of algorithmic
governance and instance takes on
intervention approach I ask how can we
actually design algorithmic governance
that is effective yet also respects the
values and interests of all stakeholders
and one of the keys here is to is that
stakeholders includes both those who
make decisions and those who are
affected by those decisions so to
address these questions I explore a
participatory approach meaning
participation from all stakeholders the
question of how to create an
organization or service or product
that is Lizabeth visit MIT and benefits
all involved is actually on old
questions with a long history
participation of citizen in policymaking
has been shown to improve perceives
legitimacy and trustworthy governing
organizations in another benefit of
involving stakeholders is that
stakeholder themselves know the most
about their unique needs and problems
and participation allows policymakers or
designer to leverage those knowledgeable
so as this is a chec class I think
everyone knows the benefit of user
centered design and why we have to ask
first users about their needs and tailor
the system design and finally citizens
or stakeholder can help operationalize
moral values or a trade-off that are
involved in policy such as the trade-off
between fairness and efficiency so in
the literature on participation
participatory governance for policies
requiring a trade trade-off that in fact
different our community differently
asking community members themselves is
proposed as a way to adjudicate the
trade-offs so this suggests that having
stakeholders participate in algorithmic
governance can be a fruitful approach
but the implementation of policy in an
algorithmic form poses a new challenge
in the case of algorithm that managed
organizations such as task assignment or
the governance public institutions such
as schools or hiring the algorithm
embody a set of guiding principles for
actions in the form of objective
functions constrain and features how can
we provide a usable way for people to
provide input on these algorithmic
policy and this challenge has relevance
to a question for a to a question that
human in the lab or interactive machine
learning has been investigating but the
difference here
is that algorithm that cover multiple
people or involve multiple stakeholders
we need a way to consolidate potentially
varying opinions of those different
people so the project that I will be
presenting today addresses these
challenges and investigates a way to
enable people to participate in the
design process of algorithms that
governs them so in this talk I will
first present a design space for such a
participatory framework then I will
present our framework we build AI and
our cool development process we use it
in working with a nonprofit called for
1/2 foot rescue so let's start with the
design space so there are many different
ways which participation can be
configured for algorithmic governance so
to understand its potential design space
I drew on the field of political science
so political science is appropriate
because the field has investigated
collective decision-making and effective
citizen participation in governance in
this body work of work offers
considerations that designers of
participatory framework should consider
so for the sake of time I will just
briefly go over each of them so first
one is to determine what policy issues
will leverage participants opinions and
how directly participate participants
input will influence and it will be
implemented as a final policy and the
next step is to determine who the
participate participate SAR and then a
participant needs to know the
algorithmic policy issues and choices
and establish their personal beliefs on
the matter
and once we individuals form their
opinions multiple participants opinions
need to be consolidated and finally the
outcome should be explained so that
people know that
they're all in poetry use and feel
rewarded and they can this will allow
them to further monitor the system as
the system makes decisions in the field
so our framework considered these
components with specific design traits
are made for each of them first our
framework enables our direct
participation so by direct participation
I mean that people are able to specify
the objective metrics functions and
behaviors in order to create desirable
algorithmic behaviors and this develop
Roache can minimize potential errors or
biases in codifying policy ideas into
computational algorithm and this was
important for us because this errors and
translations has been highlighted as a
risk in algorithmic governance in
previous work so in our framework we
first used both scenario based training
and explicit rulemaking tweetly elicited
individual belief and once individual
models are created each model plays a
role of a voter ranking decision
alternatives and once these individual
rankings are aggregated vir at a border
voting approach the TV's the global
rankings are used to generate final
recommendations and these
recommendations are explained in the
interface that administrative this is a
maker use so that our participants know
that their input has been used in these
final recommendations so we apply this
framework to the context of fair
donation allocation service working with
for 1 to 4 rescue the foreign civil
rescue is like uber for charities they
take food donation from donors such as
grocery store restaurants and retail
stores and allocate them to nonprofit
that help on
served food insecure communities the
examples include food pantries homeless
shelters our soup kitchens or public
housing or facility for older adults or
young children's and they use an app to
coordinate volunteers to pick up and
deliver the donation to the nonprofit
and the organization has been are quite
successful they currently work with
about 600 donor-recipient organizations
and have a pool of thousands of
volunteers the amount of food they they
have rescued is over 3 million pounds
for the past two years but currently
they have only few employees making
these allocation decisions and because
of the demand for fast excuse ins many
decisions are often made for convenience
which result in skew donation
distributions so they would like to
introduce an algorithmic system to help
them make allocation decisions and to
make the allocation more efficient and
fairer
so our research addresses this goal so
the allocation algorithm effort if a
rescue seeks to balance two factors one
is efficiency the distance between the
pick-up and drop-off locations and this
determines the time the volunteers need
to drive the other factor is maximizing
the utility of the donations by giving
them to recipient organizations with
greater needs a major donors are often
located in wealthy areas in listen
Pittsburgh which creates trade-off
between efficiency and equity so for
example giving donation to nearby
organizations all the time will be
fission in terms of overall travel
mileage which is fair for volunteers and
four-on-two for rescue who needs to put
an effort to recruit those volunteers
but if the donate that will mean the
recipient organization in wealthier area
will get most of the donations but if
donations are sent further away to food
and secure food laser area with higher
poverty the donation has better
utilities but volunteers need to travel
further so use our a participatory
framer to address this trade-off take
when we took a normative approach so the
stakeholder had varying ideas of how to
define recipients level of needs and how
it should be balanced with the travel
time by having these stakeholders
collectively defined with logarithmic
goal we wanted to create a service that
is transparent and follows a policy that
all stakeholders agree on and having a
service that reflects what they think is
right and that they feel they can trust
will sustain the service by further
motivating to participate they can
donate more they can volunteer more and
the recipients can sign up for donations
and we got the opinions from four types
of for one - for rescue stakeholders
donors recipient organizations volunteer
and for one to rescue staff recover
recruitment was volunteer based which
with the constraint that each of the
volunteer each of the participants
should have a qualifying experience with
the service and the co development
process happened over to four to five
individual sessions with each
participant and one workshop over a
year-long period for the rest of the
presentation I will not go over the
details and study study detail and data
collection method but in general we got
participant feedback after try each step
of the framework deserve question
how higher stakes in this for all the
participants you can imagine a spectrum
from like we don't we don't have we
don't really care about this but like it
will have some minor effect on us - like
I would potentially no longer
participate in this endeavor if this
isn't done well and I imagine this sort
of kinds of participation and how how
hard people will hold on to their goals
and so on with the Kenda on how how how
much mistake they they feel like they
have in this and like how much is that
stake so what what was your sense for
the other choice so that's a very
interesting question for this one thing
that I want to say this is not like life
or death matter but for this particular
service the introduction of algorithm
system instead of a human dispatcher
could come with a risk because a lot of
the success of the service a lot of
stakeholder have a high trust in the
organization and people who are running
it and the fact that the automation
system will replace those human decision
making they the organization perceive it
as a risk and losing some of the
stakeholders so in terms of the
sustainment a maintenance of the service
the design good design of the algorithm
mattered yeah because right now if they
rely on their like recipient and
volunteers though they all rely on their
trust in the individual who are running
the organizations but they have no idea
what will happen if they start to use
more automated decision aids transfer
over to an algorithm so what this is
kind of a double edge of transparency so
a lot of stakeholder had a lot of trust
in people running it but the
organization themselves they and
acknowledge that their donation has been
very skewed because they don't have any
tools that help them make this
so they in this service they keep giving
it to organizations that it's been
receiving donation so about like 20
percent of organization gets 80 percent
of the donations and they wanted to more
equally distributed donations to more
recipient that sign up for their service
so there was a one reason the other one
is much more Israelite is about
efficiency because there is only like
three staff that are making decision and
they have to make decision fast and it's
a lot of work to us think about who whom
to give it to and posting your line so
the volunteer signs up so they wanted to
some hand off those cognitive effort and
time yeah to the algorithm yeah
but they although the stakeholders
shared one goal being altruistic and
helping people in need so yeah so you
know to understate what features should
be used by this algorithm we first
conducted formative interviews with
these stakeholders the goal was to
understand our people think fair
allocation is and what information
should be used to make such decisions so
from the factor that participant
mentioned we selected ones that most
people mentioned and had reliable data
sources so for example distribution
capability was mentioned but there was
no objective metrics for measuring it
and there's no existing database so it
didn't it was not included in our
feature so at the end we had three
categories of features first features of
the recipient organization that
indicated they their clients news and
this include our organization size our
income level poverty rate and the food
access level of the neighborhood where
this their clients live the second
factor was distance between the
recipients and donors and it was a bad
trick of efficiency in this our service
and third the factor that influence
allocation patterns over time such as
when each recipient received the last
donations and how much they received in
total so using these features we next
investigated what people think is a
Farrell algorithm allocation we use two
bottles iteratively so the first method
was most in learning based so we
presented pair of I scenarios that show
two recipients they varied along the
factor that I show in the last slide and
as people to choose which organizations
should receive this donations
participant-centered about 50 pairwise
comparison questions and then we use
machine learning using a random utility
model we also experiment weighted
techniques for learning utility model
but at the end the linear regression was
the best accuracy in terms of accuracy
and it was the simplest to explain in
the second model we asked people to
create their model by explicitly writing
down scores or weights for each factors
and this was an explicit design
decisions because we wanted to see where
the participants were developing
consistent rules when they're answering
the pairwise our scenario questions we
use a scoring model in instead of
distant tree or other model because they
capture the method of balancing factors
that people identify when answering the
pairwise comparison questions
comparisons so we were predicting in
this case among the two which recipient
will be chosen by this particular
individual weights weights times
features you get a number when that
number telling you the higher the number
it is
is more likely to be chosen by the
recipients it's always the supervision a
little confused because usually the
linear regression would have some
continuous outcome it's trying to
predict so what was the continuous
outcome so this excellent question the
read here we were predicting the scores
but as a way to evaluate it later you
see the number we were just using it
with the we tested the algorithm with a
two comparison case and just looked at
the the winner or the chosen recipient
and whether the actual participant chose
the recipient but we use the continuous
outcome because later this model will be
used to rank all possible alternative
recipients and gave scores to turn the
pairwise comparisons into continuous
score we use the random utility model to
make that as continuous yeah and after
once the user created the model we gave
people an options to answer additional
pairwise comparison to up if their
thinking has changed when answering
those when creating the scoring model
and in fact oh except one chose to
answer the questions again so they
retrain their machine learning model
after they create these scoring rules
and after they finish all the process of
building these models we ask people to
answer a new set of 50 pairwise
comparison question so that we can use
them to test accuracy of the both models
so once they complete this model
building sessions we show the
participant both model at the machine
learning one and the user creating one
and for to do that for each feature we
show the science scores along along the
input range and here the higher scores
indicates recommendations
so we then asked people to choose a
representative model between the machine
learning one and one the user created so
in order to prevent so here in this hand
all you see the model acts Emoto I here
the Moto X is a machine learning model
they learned through machine learning
and the orange one is the one that user
created and in order to prevent any
potential biases in favor of the model
that they directly specifies we
anonymize the model using cooling Emoto
X&Y and normalize the two models
parameter using the maximum scores
assigned in each model and introduced
both model as object of those like
participants creations and we show the
prediction agreement score and presented
all pairwise comparison cases in which
to model disagreed with each other
or disagree with the participants
choices within the testing set and then
you see here's some example model the
participant created so for some like the
one that you see on the left both models
look quite a very similar but for this
one that you see on the right you see
that the model learned from a similar
machine learning versus model that they
directly specified varied a lot so let's
talk about models people chose so this
person was had a particular so in this
case the unit of donation unit of each
incoming donation is carload of food and
this person thinks that giving it to
Carlo refer to a bigger organization
they serve many clients doesn't make big
impact so they wanted to optimize your
organization aside to the middle because
this person think that they will
maximize the utility of the donation
so we all right I thought people
specified a video model no they could
create because of science course so
realize that the machine my mom's always
been here but there is not surprisingly
actually people do these are people
without any training in programming
necessarily and they actually didn't
figure out which model was which so yeah
but at the end everyday chose a model we
tell tall people like which model was
which for some people the method of
create a model model matter which I will
explain later so they requested those
information for that case for one person
we told them that this is a model that
you created directly and then because we
saw some nonlinear models there we try
to we try it like quadratic models but
it didn't really improve the most
learning accuracy so we stopped which
just kept using to just linear
regression so let's look at one model
simple chose so this table shows the
performance of both of machine learning
and user created models and the number
in each cell shows the accuracy and the
bolded one shows the model the
participant shows as a representative
model and I like to mention that our
purpose was not compare these two method
of making the model or claiming the
which one performs better and the reason
why most in learnt morning model perform
better in our case was we believe that
because it's the model that they created
less and reflected their most recent
thinking so on average the person
learning model perform pretty well
everything about somewhere between 80
percent to 90 percent accuracy and it
was better than user created models
however it was interesting note that
people didn't always
use a model with higher performance is
highlighted in with the blue boxes and
our interviews with the participant tell
us more about why and what participants
thought about these mock method of
building the model first the iterative
use of both mod methods seemed to be
effective as intended many participants
said that the answering the pairwise
comparison questions help them
familiarize with the decision task and
the problem set but some also commented
that they find they felt like they were
applying rules inconsistently and they
couldn't make up their minds so when
creating the user created models after
creating those answering the pairwise
comparison questions they're in a way
for us to reconcile those inconsistency
and difference conflicting beliefs so
for example one participant told us that
she was using the organization size it's
a factor in consistently sometimes
favoring the smaller organization
sometimes favoring big organizations but
when she was first to write down the
rules she made her mind that
organization size shouldn't matter at
all and what was interesting was that
for some people being method itself
seemed to have influenced the rules that
they make so some participant told me
that they felt emotional when answering
pairwise comparison questions so for me
or to a third person a list of those
after a factor actually didn't evoke any
emotions but because either stakeholders
for familiar with many recipient
organizations when answering those
questions they were reminded of actual
recipients that fit those
characteristics and sometimes choosing
one over the other was a very difficult
decisions on the other hand pert many
participant mentioned that the process
of building the scoring model was very
robotic because they are assigning
scores to an abstract feature and this
difference in to influence people's
believe expressed in the model so for
example this slide shows that the model
that a human decision made
great for tuefel rescue are created so
she mentioned that the operational
concerns was more salient when she was
answering the pairwise comparison
questions and she prioritized the
distance so if you see the blue lines
here the weight of the score no income
poverty organization size are very small
compared to the way she raised at the
distance but when she was creating the
scoring model she was going for her
ideal self and creating equal giving
more waist to the factor that
characterizes the recipients needs and
at the end she when she was reviewing
this model she chose the one that she
she specified by answering the pairwise
comparison questions because she
couldn't ignore the operational concerns
but on the other hand a director of a
food pantry told us that he only
believes I'm in the model that he
directly created using the abstract
rules because he needs to follow a set
of rule that he believes are right not a
rule that was derived from case-by-case
decisions so he was he was he in his
mind the using the abstract factors and
scoring ways to directly to those
feature was the right way of determining
this criteria so this is how our framer
in the stated individual belief and now
we explained how we aggregated this
belief using a voting method so when
given a new donation each individual
model generates a complete ranking of
all possible recipient organizations and
the bore averting rule aggregates is
ranking and create recommendations based
on the number of votes each option are
received we use porta because it
provides a theoretical guarantees in the
face of noise estimates of true
preferences the details are out of this
scope for this presentation but you can
find more information on in the manual
screen
shown on the slide we also asked
participant whether stakeholder need to
have equal voting power and they told us
that they were foreign to the rescues
opinion to be most reflected because
they are they want their operating
services followed by recipient
organizations volunteers and donors so
we use these ways to when aggregating
individual rankings and as a final step
we explain to participants how their
participation influences the final
result so we first show the average
models that aggregated different
stakeholders belief and then showed an
interface we built with an explanation
of recommendations generally from these
collectively built algorithms
I'll play a video to show how this
interface words all the recipients names
presenting here all replace with
pseudonyms but the recommendations are
real and were actually generated for an
incoming donations so you see the
recommendations generated
so once the recommendation is generated
all the potential recipients the
potential recipients are presented in
the bottom as a box so the top person
shows specifics planation for chosen
recipients and the bottom person shows
all potential recipients ranked by the
border scores and we explain the
decisions based on the input influence
so here you see that this particular
organization was recommended because
it's close to the donor and then hasn't
received donation for three month we
show the port awarding score on top at
the circle to show as an indicator of
the consensus among the participating
stakeholders and we show the border
prefers ranking
in the bottom here as a visual reminder
that this recommendation was generally
from the collective participation so
these design like both stakeholder
models and the interface were ways to
show participant how their participation
influence the final algorithm and
service operations
so overall participants were positive
about the collective decision process so
in terms of the voting based aggregation
method which was kind of a automatic
people were actually quite receptive the
many said that they found the fact that
each model ranked all recipients and the
algorithm area of all those ranking
acknowledged the recognizer subtleties
in the decisions and coded Democratic so
I'd like to note that when we are
explaining this aggregation process to
participant we actually never use the
word are voting or democratic in the
process and we use it as a rating
mechanism so that was interesting that
they kind of thought about they made our
knowledge to human governance systems
and in the way we explain our product
and the participant asleep appreciated
that the interface directly show the
their their participation when it was
explained the recommendations seeing
other stakeholders models on the other
hand are prompted more varying reactions
some reacted positively that to the fact
that they are all share similar guiding
high-level principles in other words
people waited organization with high
poverty rate more than lower poverty
rate and no one wanted to give more to a
recipient in the wealthy neighborhood in
participant also waited distances are
important factors often choosing is one
of the top three very factors in their
models so this pattern gave participant
assurance that no matter what group or
in
dividual refitting we have the same
require for the food and the individual
that we are serving but the difference
in the model occurred in the ways people
weight organization size and how they
balance the efficiency factors like
distance with recipient needs factors in
some are in fact glad to see these
differences and they were okay with
accepting the outcomes from model that
uses different model because there is
the point of democracy but to
participant were disappointed that
default of a rescue staff was not
waiting travel time was not was waiting
travel times significantly more than
other factors like poverty rate and it
made them question the organization's
what was interesting to me was that for
the three four one two food rescue staff
we showed individual model because there
was no privacy concern and they wanted
to know how their co-workers are making
the decisions and seeing the individual
model actually increase awareness of
their internal inconsistency in making
the decisions so while all staffed act
according to the same principle and had
discussed the principles multiple times
in the model their model varied in the
ways they rate poverty organization size
and distance so there was a surprise to
them and also seeing the other
stakeholders model also prompted the
staff to revisit their own thinking so
one of the common assumptions the food
to the rescue had is that distance
matters and even saving one two or three
a few minutes of driving times will
influence the the volunteers how fast
they can get the volunteer for those
rescues but after seeing the models the
volunteers created and then seeing that
they didn't wait travel time it's highly
as they Ashiya thought she questioned
her evaluation of her travel time she
said like maybe volunteers don't care as
much
maybe you end up hearing from the people
who care and whom we have complaints
about the distance so I explained the
process of developing the allocation
algorithm with stakeholders and how we
applied our framework and then lessons
that we learn in the process so in the
final part of this talk I'd like to go
over the effect of the framework on the
resulting algorithms and participants
our attitudes so let's look first look
at the algorithmic outcomes so we tested
how algorithm our algorithm worked using
a 5-month of historical data from March
to August in 2018 it included records of
about 1900 donations they came from
about 200 donors and this data shows how
a human dispatcher f12 for rescue has
assigned donations to which recipients
and using this data as a benchmark we
evaluated these algorithms so during
this period there was about 400
recipient organizations that could
receive donation and we for each given
donation we restricted alternative safes
according to the food type that this
recipient can handle in their operation
are and with this restricted said we
compared the algorithm allocation to the
human allocation in recruiting in the
data and to a random allocations so
let's first look at the donation
distributions so the x-axis here is the
total number of donations a y-axis shows
the number of recipient organization
they received a number of donations the
orange line shows the human allocation
in the blue line is the algorithmic
allocations and the grey one is the
random allocations so this graph shows
that with human allocation donating is
really skewed about nine year initiation
getting one and with a long tail of
organization they got up to sixty
donations
so the algorithm a location is more
normally distributed with a small tail
compared to the random algorithm that is
most normally distributed so in terms of
the rescue distance the algorithm a
location reduced the average distance
per rescue so the average rescue was
seven about seven miles long in
algorithm allocation compared to nine
miles in human allocations so this means
about ten minutes less driving for
volunteers so this may sound small for
from the perspective of people living in
California but it means a lot in
Pittsburgh where organizations are not
spread out and in this food rescue
context it is important for the for food
safety as well this graph shows another
look at distance it shows the total
distance that volunteer needed to drive
over five months yeah while x-axis
showed the rescues in the order from the
first rescue to the last rescue and it
shows that algorithm allocation had
about 30,000 fewer miles in total than
human allocations so finally in terms of
characteristics of recipient who gets to
donations our algorithm gave to more
organization in higher poverty areas
compared to human allocations so the
average poverty rate of recipient was
about 21% in human collocation compared
to 25% in algorithm allocation and here
you see the EXCI humor allocation
pattern is similar to random one except
the this area between 30 to 40 poverty
rate where they gave more to recipient
with those poverty rates in algorithmic
allocation you see they give less to
organization with 10 to 15 a person
poverty rate and give more to
organization you know higher poverty
rate around 50%
and the process of participation didn't
just influence the allocation it also
influenced the participants attitude
toward the organization's so it just
suggested in the literature on
participatory policymaking participation
improve stakeholders perceived fairness
and Trust in the organization's they
mentioned that the organization was
putting a priority on fairness being
open to new ideas and including all
stakeholder in process was a signal that
they are trustworthy and care the
important values that they all share
about Sherrod and for the one
participant said there are everybody
sees everybody's brain power who are
deemed to be important decision and this
process is the most fair that you could
get and what was interesting was the
participant also seems to develop more
empathetic stance toward the
organization's so they mentioned that
they understood the difficulty that
organization faces and that there might
not be one perfect solution in this in
this space so this is an important
change because it can improve people's
tolerance and understanding of trade-off
that is involved in any governor's
decisions however a participant had also
concerned about our approach of directly
applying participants input to the final
algorithm while in our context most of
them were okay with this outcome to
participant had concerned that if other
participant had paid equal level of
attention to the model that they built
and whether they have any relevant
experiences they qualify them to provide
the input what was more surprising to me
was that the changes in people's
attitude toward the algorithm as a
technology so I'd like to remind you
that these participant didn't have any
programming background and one
surprising moment was when one
participants told us in a very
unprompted way that he now believes in
algorithm
heartily because he was very skeptical
in the beginning that algorithm can make
such decisions that involves carrying
others but after seeing the step-by-step
process of building and seeing them how
the model performs well in terms of
predicting his answers he now believes
that algorithm can make such decisions
and trustee decisions another
interesting comment that people share
with us was that some became more aware
of the role of human in the process of
developing algorithms so one participant
told us that he now thinks that things
about developers of algorithm system
when he sees the system around him like
Facebook and he thinks that his judgment
of algorithmic fairness will be based on
how it was developed who's behind it and
how its programmed and how its
influenced so what do these result mean
in terms of potential of a participatory
framework for creating algorithmic
governance that respects the values and
interests of all stakeholders so our
study suggests that a participatory
framework an increase algorithmic
awareness and actually fairness in
governance systems so as I mentioned
algorithmic awareness improve both at an
individual and an organizational level
so aro individual level participant felt
that they better understood what an
algorithm was and had more appreciation
for the kinds of decisions that
algorithm can make what was interesting
was the at an organizational level the
process of eliciting individual models
allow them to be more aware of their
internal instances inconsistency and
biases and provide opportunity for them
to revisit their own assumptions and
finally having all stakeholders make
this algorithm make people aware that
this algorithm can have a disparate
effect the participant
- framer also improved the algorithmic
fairness so in our framework participant
could incorporate how they thought on
Algren should work into the service and
consistent with theories on procedural
justice participant thought that both
the process and the outcome of the
algorithm were fair and in general
improve their attitude toward the
organization's the findings on different
results from different belief imitation
model in this station models also for
implications for current research on
procedural justice in algorithmic
fairness so emerging work is exploring
how to better incorporate a procedural
justice in algorithm the for example
there is a work that asks people what
features should or should not be
considered in recidivism risk
predictions or how factors should be
weighed in organ donation or
self-driving car behaviors in all these
study actually use very different method
of illustrating those belief some are
more visceral some are concrete and some
are very abstract and this study shows
that the method of asking these
questions can influence the kind of rule
they really listen our our study also
points out a few research area then need
further research particularly if we want
to directly incorporate participants our
input into final algorithm design in
other applications the first further
research is needed to understand
measures and metrics of individual input
belief quality and additionally our
participant didn't have polarize
opinions in our context and it was
altruistic and not competitive settings
but we don't know whether how
participation can work together in a
more competitive poor polarized context
so in such environment maybe public
deliberation is more needed before the
automatic aggregations so it's our next
step I plan to examine the
organizational effects in the real world
so I'm working on integrating the
decision aid interface into the forum to
further ask us actual operations
it would then
how they adopt this too and how these
two influences their organization
practice I'm also interested in further
examining the outcome efficacy of this
collectively built algorithm and there
is a research on visible cross but daven
mostly applied to a domain where there
is an objective or ground truth measured
and I like to see whether this concept
applies to more moral value lay decision
that doesn't have with effective ground
truth to conclude I'd like to end with
our story so there are many stories and
warnings about algorithm and a I being
unfair in the media right now but in
fact there is anecdotal evidence they
have many public decisions have been
historically of unfair all along without
ever receiving on equal amount of
attention and public scrutiny defining
fair algorithm governance is a
challenging problems but it also
provides an opportunity for us to enable
fairer public governance at a new scale
so by enabling everyone both those who
are using the AI and who are affected by
by AI to participate in shaping the
future of AI I hope to contribute to a
fair trustworthy and more inclusive
society I like to acknowledge that this
is a huge team effort my collaborator
prakasha
wonderful team of students and for
wonderful rescue staff all provide a
valuable insight and we are working on
writing of the result that we presented
today so and we are happy to share the
current manuscripts on this slide with
you and we are welcoming all the
feedback so thank you for your attention
and I welcome any questions
you